Hi my name is Jon Harmon.
I run the R4DS
online learning community.
Our community operates
primarily through a Slack team
and we invite R learners
at all skill levels
to join us at r4ds.io/join
Among other things,
we host book clubs
for R related books.
Whenever we start a new cohort
for one of the book clubs,
we need to find a time
that works for as many
of the people interested in
reading the book as we can.
We used to use a generic
free online app for everyone
to sign up.
Everyone would
type in their name,
choose their available
times and days,
and then set a password
in case they wanted
to edit their selections.
Sometimes people
would sign up twice,
not remembering the John who
was signed up already was them.
At least one time someone
had a typo in their name,
so when they came back to
change their available hours,
it counted as a new person.
And of course, sometimes
we legitimately
had multiple people with the
same name of signing up.
So I didn't have any way to sort out
who was who and how many duplicates
we had.
And even when everything
went smoothly,
I didn't have an
easy way to connect
the information in that
app to their Slack user.
So, I couldn't contact
people directly
to let them know that
a cohort was being
created at a time they'd chosen.
So I figured, we already all
have logins to for R4DS Slack.
What if we made our
own app in Shiny
and then connected
that to the Slack API?
Then the app could
talk to our Slack
and connect each user to
their identity on R4DS.
I posted the idea on our
Slack and one of our users,
Priyanka Gagneja,
volunteered to make
the initial app minus
the login, and then I
focused on the login part.
I'd already done some
work with Yoni Sidi
on his slackteams
package, which
allows you to talk
to Slack through R.
You can find that and
Yoni's whole slackverse
family of packages on GitHub
at yonicd slash slackteams.
My goal was to take what I did
there with interactive Slack
authorization, make
it work in Shiny,
and then wrap that up into
an easy to use package.
So this is what that looks like.
If you aren't
already logged in, it
asks you to log in using Slack.
From that initial screen, you're
taken to Slack's permission
screen to connect to
your Slack account,
and then it returns
you to the Shiny app.
Here we just use the connection
to identify the user,
but I have another
app where we use
it to make sure the
user has permission
to see certain messages.
And I'm working on one that will
help users ask better questions
and then post those
questions as them.
So it works.
Now let's see how I did on the
easy to use part of the goal.
You can install
this from GitHub at
R4DS slash shinyslack.
This is one of the ways we
can launch a normal Shiny app.
We define a UI, define
a server function,
and wrap them in Shiny's
shinyApp function.
Now we'll use shinyslack to
add a Slack login to that app.
We replace Shiny's shinyApp
with shinyslack's shinyslack
app.
We also need to give it the code
that identifies our Slack team,
and that's it.
Well, kind of.
So you probably want to
deploy your app to something
like shinyapps.io, not
just run the app locally.
And to do that, you'll need
your own Slack app that
has permission to
send people to apps
hosted on your
Shiny apps account.
When I first started
working on this,
setting up the Slack side of
things was really complicated.
I was kind of dreading
explaining this part.
I mean, I just did
that thing showing you
how easy it is to set up
the Shiny side of this.
And this part was
going to ruin that.
But then something
magical happened.
Slack added an option to create
a Slack app from something
called a manifest. So I added
a function over in slackteams,
create custom app,
to make that easy.
There's a vignette
explaining it,
but basically you call create
custom app with a couple
arguments and copy
paste the result
into Slack's app creation form.
And with that, you can wrap
your Shiny app with shinyslack
and integrate it
with your Slack team.
If you'd like to learn more, stop
by the R4DS Slack at r4ds.io/join
We're putting
together a new club
where we'll walk through
side projects like this
so you can learn all
about how this works
under the hood over there.